so I enjoy great works of art you know
Sistine Chapel of course beautiful I
belong I know what the Great Wall isn't
a piece of artwork but it is a a
man-made achievement yeah
bill turkey that we goes out yes Ryan
calm I love it in the museum's and I
love seeing beautiful even albums like
album like sergeant Pepper's lion
beetles yeah yeah and you know over the
years I haven't really seen great art
until this weekend and I bought tickets
to see a movie called choker and I saw
an actor and that movie do the best back
acting work out now it just has all new
finish careful everyone want I can you
okay this is the screen okay this is the
screen right here okay
yeah and when you could act only having
this much of your face in a screen also
just think of this still in a split
second so this is this is only on the
screen for a split second Bobby - this
is what you see right right this way
okay Bobby right at the end of my right
and this in the acting in this second I
stood up no in the theatre you didn't
say that you know what I said I'll be
honest with you I stood up I said loser
I turned it everyone in the field item I
don't know Bobby
in fact I told you this earlier when he
was in the bathroom right
my girlfriend's knees from the
Philippines right was in the theater
okay
when you we heard your voice yeah on
kalila goes hey did the knees Bobby no
that's just friend ain't nowhere to the
knees super shitty it's a big movie
my mom takes me she I went she goes I'm
gonna see the jokesters I'm excited you
know she loves yeah yeah I'm excited to
see bride like no doubt mom three hours
later she goes oh I didn't see Bryan are
you even on the call sheet when you're
that like I got a call he was out there
for a while I got a call and took four
days probably for the other four and and
Todd was like hey just come out and do
this little part I do anything he tells
me cuz I love this year at my age yeah
is the most money the most everything
I've ever done is this year good it gets
better and better
alright and there are people bullies
like you right these are [ __ ] comedy
but looks like you you I'll just do it
you write Joe Rogan yeah mark is a
little bit like that
Marc Maron a little bit okay to me oh is
it a yeah you you're definitely again I
know and when I shoot you did we throw
tonight when I used to see you back in
the day I used to feel joy why now it's
kind of dread no no no yeah a little bit
when I see you like what did I run into
the other day cuz I'm a boy store cuz
I'm a boy yeah get scared they're gonna
pull me into something and you and Rogan
and I I know what you're wrong that's
why I'm here
that is what don't step don't get
nervous friend cuz when I went up when I
shoot up school no you're you're not on
the list no yes
I handle no first guy way only colleague
bro I would shoot you but I'm your fairy
hundred times in just your stupid
[ __ ] face that you guys just saw no
cuz my career that's all you're here
your career my your careers a mate dude
your career is the reason why I'm here
you just made fun of my [ __ ]
performance I know because no kidding
to be a part of like you know you're
kind of a bully too you [ __ ] didn't
return my he didn't return my texts and
then you returned mine yeah oh you want
me tell you so bride we need a special
guest for the 500 episode right and so
we're trying to do it I text him twice
nothing and I went Bobby Lee be perfect
guest for this big episode yeah it does
a seem special though
they're really like streamers or there's
no extra leg like a little thing well we
have something well we'll see the the
shows not open right now I'm gonna so I
put yo job you around this coming
Wednesday we're doing the 500 fire the
kid once you be a guest please and he
put I'm in I don't respond to Brian
because he's an old see you Wednesday
[Laughter]
yeah we have to bleep out in stores now
now hold on you know it's do you have a
wish you I never did that oh my god you
got caught now you're embarrassed I
never did that man you're wrong bro
that wasn't my tax right that wasn't you
know that was that was actually
pretending to be Bobby Lee you're a
bully dude you're the comedy bully oh
you think I am that's impossible
you're a good I bully anybody I'm not an
alpha male well I like the 50 shades of
red though huh have no muscles on my
body you've seen my body yeah what what
do you mean I know what's so funny this
is great dude I'm glad we're here ching
chong right I'm so glad we're here we
can really just kind of get it out we
can get it all out there yeah yeah
that's good because I honestly and I'm
gonna leave this is not even a bit I
feel whew tension with you guys yeah a
little bit ya know you get from my
girlfriend [ __ ] guys wow dude well I
hate to say this everyone gives your
girlfriend [ __ ] guys
hey come on easy stop giving him you're
giving him serious eyes now you're
giving an accusation eyes my body just
do a hard restart Harley Bobby you don't
want a guy just now I felt that and I
felt but here's the thing though that's
I get mad that you drive a Ferrari and
people look at it yeah you know what
sign up drive Ferrari also girls girls
want to make this job that's here smart
girls when I'm eight was shopping their
instinct their instinct a lot of times I
see giant the giant yeah yeah a dress
like candy yeah
he's shiny and he's cute be cool there
honestly does does he have a thing in
this car a blue thing though you can't
park anywhere oh one of those
handicapped I don't want to say that
because yeah one of those uh nope
okay but I just parked wait I know what
you're saying I know what you're [ __ ]
saying oh yeah this is so [ __ ] me
what do I say you say you're suggesting
that he has he has a learning problem
that he looks like he's a little bit
mentally challenged what is really
that's what you [ __ ] cuz you looked
at him at you know your your face or
something yeah watch your voice getting
on oh that's where you're going with
this where were you going with it what
yeah what did you mean by a guy missing
a little bit of uh dude I'll tell you
why can I tell you why you can't I never
said this no you can't oh I know what it
is he looks like George from my sand man
yes no Lenny look honey I killed any
white dude that size with that big of a
head he'll demand what you say when you
say a Brandon and he turns around and
his eyes do this a little bit and you're
like oh there's something wrong like Oh
things yeah dude that's not nice let's
go let's call up your girl see what
she's like oh let's talk like this let's
call up your girl see what she thinks
let's go up you're [ __ ] my girls no
you like a look at Rogan now and I look
at bill burr maybe why what do you mean
just say you know I'm standoffish a
little bit a little like a little
distance yeah that's not true trust him
what because I long yeah [ __ ] yeah
your success that's such [ __ ] I've
never thought that in my life yeah I
don't star of your own show No
so what I don't feel like I said that I
saw the numbers yesterday very good oh
nine one point oh yeah we do you know so
funny because out of every oh yeah
that's why I'm here
back up turn that off oh yeah he's going
hard huh 500 I'm under I gotta go hard
so we're this is about honesty it's
about honor
flashing out some issues yeah you
stopped buying its girl
you stop thinking I'm so successful and
amazing and B I don't think that I don't
think that I don't think no you can't my
actors you bolt you and I you shove you
around the hallway a little bit sometime
a lot okay you get really physical and
then you'll come up and you'll grab the
neck yeah and you'll do more Thai like
lunges yeah I might throw or my chest
regions I like you can see when I'm
talking to like agents or something
important we look foolish but friends
were gonna shirt that says fighters
clubs let's just acknowledge that yeah I
came to the I knew it was gonna bother
you I showed up with my when my my I got
a bunch of stuff from eight-man strong
yeah cuz CB Dollaway that's his company
yeah it says eight-man strong and I knew
and I walked in with a teacup sweatshirt
says eight-man strong yeah roasted but
he would be like he was like that
bothers me don't walk around like that
cuz and you actually physically grabbed
the one that makes most of the money all
right Bobby
why are you looking about that right now
but I had this just show sure everyone
Korean in the room so this says he knows
he gets you know he doesn't eat all your
number-one provides for the vision you
don't get it you doofus piece of [ __ ]
huh you know what was a shirt I was at
oh yeah I was in Portland doing a show
and the front row four dudes with the
pocket shirt yeah right say finally like
I said I you screamed at everyone's a
demon where do I love my dad so much
[Applause]
now it comes out that's what was behind
him that was behind his face the whole
time about he doesn't even deserve one
career to come here and you tell
straight you can put your shirt have a
little with a meathead you can have a
little sign my buddies at my you're
blending in with the couch so hard it's
red homewrecker breathing so hard with
the couch but if you can pull your shirt
down a tiny bit you know I mean that's
what I want to get out of here I'm
feeling bad vibes right
he's Bobby alright we love here I love
you my realer you're earning I like
really deciding that's that he's got
given eyes to your girl you've decided
as a joke do you know that I fully these
are all jokes these are fake money
relationship right angles they take or
kneecaps women but at the end of the day
I finish what I'm going to say you
[ __ ] sorry but hey it hit you hit you
struck both of us
we've never been hit on our podcast and
you physically accosted I've never been
treated so poorly what thought uh
podcast I'll be honest I felt like this
all the time all right
the picture I want to explain the thing
is is that the reason why I'm here this
is the weather just but that's not what
I was gonna say this is the first
podcast I've done since my dad passed
Wow you know so this is um and the
reason I would only go to a place where
I feel at home say if you do that and
safe and that's why when you ask me to
do this I said 100% I'd like to come
home but when it came here it was a rape
party oh my oh my a party party on my
soul no don't say rape yeah and it was
spiritually raped here no and that's not
what I wanted to know so I lied I've
done like nine other podcast we got
raped now you do we were read that
you're Zach but thank good today bad I
feel like it was a chaos the worst
podcast I know I'm so sorry without a
little off I'm so sorry now you're free
have fun
are you sure you know here's a reason
why it's also scary to do your podcast
why in the reason why I haven't been on
in a while because you've been asking I
know how he does it - he does it in a
sly way and it's always like hey in one
hour can you feel it you do it it's like
what the [ __ ] yeah a lot of yeah you
don't give me a lot of leeway a good
planner yeah but um what I wanted to say
was is that um I truly um love you bye
oh man I believe I'm tell you this right
now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue Oh
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]